welcome to the end of strange loop and
I'm here to talk to you about a subject
that's a little more practical and a
little less brain melty since you've had
two days of turning your brain into like
molten silicon with the Endo's
Terminator so and I'm really excited to
speak here it's strangely if only
because I don't have to spend the first
like 2/3 of my talk explaining what
functional pre active programming is
that's really great it's like trying to
teach somebody calculus and explain why
it's cool at the same time like it's not
so easy so yeah so I was super excited
to see a lot of talks on the subject on
the schedule especially I really liked
Evans talk about Elm that was really
great there's a really great overview
how many people saw that talk it was
really cool he's a great prisoner I
loved his talks so a lot of people
presenting about function reactive
programming or presenting on theory or
talking about web frameworks and a
github in the desktop group I could have
we've been doing a lot of things around
I was a native programming so desktop
apps mobile apps anything that the ends
and app or exe or dot IPA or
apk that's what we do and we've been
using this approach for a really long
time and we're really excited about it
and so I'd like to share that with you
all so why why should we think about
this technology when I can I can write
an event handler I can an on click it'll
be great
I can save off some boolean why should
we bother so we can no longer write
synchronous software bad news I think
Bob Dylan said that but I think Abraham
Lincoln said that about him saying that
yeah so I'm going to talk about kind of
the history of two desktop applications
one for Mac and one for Windows in the
library that we built around them a lot
of what I've been saying
I'll say today applies to mobile
applications as well so you know desktop
and mobile Mobile is just desktop where
you don't have as much memory and random
bad things happen to you so all the cool
things that I've been talking about
works in both places
that's very cool so we're on 2002
github.com decided to write a first a
Mac application and then a Windows
application and these applications were
really designed back in 2000 to get was
not the paragon of usability that it is
today and so we wanted to write these
applications to make it so the people
who just wanted to get their work done
and make commits and you know create
branches and push things up to get calm
the website could do so because they
really couldn't they couldn't use they
couldn't use git so they couldn't use
github and now it was we thought that
was a bummer so both of these
applications started off as kind of best
practices imperative applications
they're written kind of the style of
what you were supposed to do at the time
using using imperative code and through
the development of it
we hired a bunch of people we're really
excited about functional programming and
so now these applications both of them
are driven almost completely by signals
by by the kind of the concepts of
functional reactive programming
everything UI events our signals
shelling out to get is a signal where
every line is an item in the signal okay
every network call is a signal every API
call the ghost the background is also a
signal that only returns one item it's
kind of a it's a really different way to
write user interface applications than a
lot of other people were doing in the
past and and we're really excited to
share this with people and so these
libraries we we kind of took out a lot
of these pieces and built
into two libraries that are kind of
complimentary one written in objective-c
and one in c-sharp and so I'll get into
that but the impetus for all of this was
library written by Microsoft written by
Eric Meyer called the reactive
extensions and this was written
originally for c-sharp was actually
written for the sequel server group
which was really strange if you think
about how they're trying to manage like
stream computing like these huge stock
worker kind of environments where they
have all this data coming in they want
to process it real-time that's what they
came up with and Evan mentioned this in
his talk this rx fits into the async
data flow model of functional reactive
programming so it's it compromises on
the principles to fit into a world that
is mostly imperative so when we write
Windows applications when you're at Mac
applications we still live in this world
of of mutable state cocoa really likes
objects that save state and you poke and
set and get in set properties and and
run methods on them we live in that
world but we can bridge a lot of it away
and that's really cool so because we
live in very mutable languages we have
to make a lot of compromises but ends up
working on so reactive extensions kind
of gives you these primitives for
creating observables which so in our ex
they call them observables and in it's
the same as a signal in reactive cocoa
and some of the other in elm they call
them signals the semantics kind of vary
between platforms so we can create
signals if you haven't heard of signals
that are kind of like events right event
is if n is the signal we can create this
signal we can transform it you can lift
operators to it
things like filters and maps and reduces
in this talk I use c-sharp syntax
because all the things that I'm saying
also apply to the Objective C version
but I find that c-sharp syntax is kind
of if you didn't know either language
then like you might be able to fix
that one on easier I also write c-sharp
everyday and think it's better so and so
we have transforming observables which
is really cool we can take simple events
and then transform them into more
interesting events we can take dumb
signals and then make them cool signals
that we're more interested in in our
application and the third thing that
provides and it's really important and
it it's a very practical compromise is
the notion of context so normally a
functional reactive programming doesn't
care about what context is running in
right it's just in order in other words
in a practical sense what thread it's
running in but unfortunately user
interface toolkits really do and so
scheduling is an abstraction that lets
us defer the results of them anytime we
defer any computation we're going to use
this object called a scheduler because
we've wrapped that we can do some
interesting things and I'll show show
that later the important thing is that
scheduling is the way to move from
background threads to the UI thread from
the UI threads to the background thread
so reactive extensions doesn't know
anything about user interfaces it
doesn't know anything about any kind of
like domain it's very domain agnostic
it's just a way to create events a way
to transform those events and a way to
schedule those events it has no
knowledge of any kind of platform so
around like early mid to 2010 I started
to write a few it's kind of almost just
helper classes around tying this very
agnostic framework to a very different
UI toolkit so trying to make it so you
don't have to think as much about moving
between threads and it will just kind of
handle it for you and so originally will
start on Windows
and now it works on every major desktop
and mobile platform so it works on
Android it works on iOS that works on
Linux and Windows and Mac so that's
really cool okay so reactive cocoa is
the same thing Objective C plus your
favorite UI toolkit whose name literally
ends in kit so app kit UI kit then we're
good
someone around 2012 I kind of introduced
these ideas to the Mac team it can help
and they were really excited about it
and they're like we got to write this in
objective-c and so reactive UI and
reactive cocoa are kind of these two
like sister libraries they they're
intentionally we like both of us we but
we all work together to make sure that
kind of all the concepts are really
consistent even though the names are a
lot different they're really like the
underlying concepts behind them are all
the same so that's really cool so there
was originally written for app kit and
objective-c because we're desktop
developers most people using reactive
cocoa or writing UI kit applications and
the new version is in development it's
being rewritten in Swift which is really
cool because Swift has types types are
great so reactive cocoa has really taken
off and it's really exciting to see and
so so much so that they kind of throw
every year at WWDC is held in San
Francisco and we throw it like a mini
conference one-day thing they call RAC
DC so reactive cocoa is always cocoa
libraries always have a prefix right and
so the prefix reactive Coco's RAC and so
it's often abbreviated that way so RAC
DC if you ever had if you're interested
in react with cocoa and you happen to be
in town for WTC I highly recommend
stopping in for the event that's very
cool so it's people were really excited
about it's really cool
so reactio I does a lot of a lot of
different things it does a lot of things
like pave over platform differences and
a lot of little kind of things to just
practice solve practical problems but it
also does some things that are really
specific to functional reactive
programming or takes a lot of the ideas
from it and one of the most these are
kind of for interesting things that it
provides it provides a way to take
properties of objects and turn them into
observables or turn them into signals
keep switching words signals events ups
are rules they're kind of related that's
the same thing
taking properties and turning them into
signals where every time the property
changes you get a new item it's really
powerful it's really powerful and
actually every domain not just user
interface programming because if you can
take an object and then watch when it
changes and do stuff based on it and
construct how a new object looks based
on a previous objects changes that's
really powerful it's actually powerful
in all all kind of programming that's
really cool so we have a method called
that called win any which lets you do
that it's called win any because you can
watch multiple properties where you can
watch for example you can say like food
bar dot Baz tell me what Baz changes and
so it'll even watch the intermediate
objects so food changes than you know
bar changed because the property above
changed so we have a way to take
properties and change them into
observables or signals I just need to
say signals all the time signals is what
the literature called it so we need a
way to take signals and turn them into
properties so if we look at like for
example like a color picker dialog right
like in Photoshop or mspaint or whatever
you usually have three three properties
red green and blue and their user input
properties people type them in but then
you have this fourth property color all
right and so color isn't like a property
that you should be setting it's really a
derived value of red green and blue and
so we have a method in reactor UI to
make sure that you're not setting these
explicitly we you construct this
property based on other inputs and as
those other puts change we render it so
that's really important
observables properties properties or
results react voi has a thing called a
command in in reactive cocoa I think
it's called action based on like the
target action framework and it's this
abstraction to model this really common
pattern of we're going to invoke
something from the UI we're going to run
it in the background and then we're
going to bring back the data back to the
UI thread and to do things like only
allow this to run once or like not
concurrently or to disable the attached
UI element when it's running so the like
canonical examples like the search
button right
you get search we have to run something
in the background we pull back the data
and then the button is enabled again and
the fourth thing is observable lists so
lists who we can watch when items are
added items are removed we can say
things like for every object run a
method on it and whether that object was
inserted on creation when it was you
know added after the fact the list gets
cleared and a new set of items get added
you need to do everything on that one
meter will list whose changes can be
observed so I tried in my examples to
take really practical examples because
I'm talking about a like a case study
kind of thing and so I'm taking I'm copy
pacing these right out of get them for
Windows so sometimes they're not very
pretty and so these aren't these aren't
like ideal beautiful examples but this
one was easy to understand so we want to
take the full sha-1 value of a commit
and we want to make the short version so
get github never just displays unless
you hover over on them the full chod
displays a nice shortened one and we're
going to say whenever whenever that
any changes select it into the short
version and then stuff into this other
property called short Chow and we can
describe how these so we're describing
how these properties are related and we
can describe in the really interesting
ways we don't have to we're not limited
to simple like filters selects we can
say like these two properties are
related by a Google search or these
properties are related by this complex
series of events that have to combine be
combined and put together
so this is a canned example so we can
create commands that run asynchronous
actions this is uses C sharps
async/await which is kind of cheating
but you can combine these two together
async/await and and observables we're
going to take that result in the stuff a
new property if anything bad happens
we're going to take the exception object
to throw bolt and then turn that into a
stream that we can pipe to the UI as
well and commands also do the very
practical thing of marshalling
marshalling objects between threads
which unfortunately you have to think
about
so observable collections are in my
opinion the weakest part of reactive UI
but I'll show them anyway because they
have a lot of potential I think and the
interesting thing about observable
collections is you can create derived
collections uniquely just like I can
take objects and select and wear them I
can take collections and then filter
them into new ones and as the original
updates the new and updates to and this
is really practical because if you have
like a like a list of model objects you
really want to select that into
something you can display in a DUI so
you want to you take a list of model
objects and you want to map them into a
list of view tiles right like tiles in a
list box so this has a lot of potential
but it actually has a lot of bugs too
unfortunately and the cool thing is that
the inputs to these this here is doing
filtering and sorting as well as mapping
and the cool thing is that the filter
and sort predicates can also be signals
and those signals can update and we
shuffle up the derived collection based
on that too so it has a lot of potential
to really simplify a lot of common UI
scenarios but you end up getting into a
lot of practical problems like
allocating too much memory you're like
you're always creating these new objects
that can be quite costly and if you're
putting them in a list box then that's
very important for we'll see you later
this is definitely an area of a lot of
potential for future versions so since
we learned all about Elm today I wanted
to just like point out a few things of
how they're related both of them both
elm and RAC and reactive UI effectively
used behaviors so behavior is like a
time a time very value it's the thing
that always has a current value when you
call win any the FIR as soon as you call
that method you get the initial value of
the property and so that means you have
you don't have to worry about the the
start state if you had like a an event
representing the change but you want to
set up your UI the initial view of it
you have to wait for everything to
change once and so this kind of solves
us through through behaviors so Elm does
a lot of really cool stuff that rx does
none of like you have to think about
scheduling and ordering you have to
think about like putting things on other
threads because the language helps you
you do this then they can do a lot of
cool things that as a library you kind
of have to compromise with Elm disallows
signals of signals rx let's he use them
but then again it let's use them because
I can't guarantee any of the nice things
at Elm does so I will really want to
talk about how this has worked
practically as a team like how how we
built these kind of production size
products using this application so some
great things high five yeah so some
great things and this was actually the
hardest part of the talk because I don't
have like an alternate knee which
decided not to use any of these things
and wrote my program imperative lis and
then found out all the bad things that
happen to me yeah I haven't written like
I just don't want to write imperative
programs anymore so I try to avoid it
so I'm not smart enough to write
stateful asynchronous applications
anymore it's too hard it's too hard in
large applications it's it's really too
hard these days in small applications
because so many things are asynchronous
as rich Hickey says it is easy but not
simple UI state has a ton of
intermediate values UI user interfaces
as a concept is essentially state like
if I have a desk and I leave a hammer in
the middle and I could walk away and
come back I expect the hammer to be
there that state all UI applications are
state and we're trying to model it in
such a way so we don't have to look at
it as much and so making sure that all
these intermediate values that show up
in our application like you know is
enabled that or you know checkbox not
checked is this intermediate value that
is tied to some piece of model code
making sure that these intermediate
values are all up-to-date is really hard
it's a cash intermediate values are cash
and cash and validation is hard
especially when this the way that we got
into this invalid state is
non-deterministic based on timing based
on race conditions so we need something
and I think this is a really good
solution
so Rx and reactive you are a consistent
model of asynchrony so if you look at
even like on the web and javascript you
look at the you know the Dom we have
callbacks
we have Dom events we have XML HTTP
requests we have a lot of different ways
to say the same thing
when we have an event and it's coming
back to us so every UI toolkit also has
eleventy billion different ways to model
asynchronous things we have promises we
have events callbacks dotnet has like at
least four that they recommended at some
point and then burned down and then
recommended a different way and then
burn it down and so one of the cool
things that rx lets you do is take a lot
of these code and write really
dumb wrappers around them so that you
don't see you can see it in a very
consistent way all using observe rules
are signals signals and you don't have
to think about and you can combine them
all together you can combine things like
you know when when it's five seconds in
or this network will quest calls comes
back even though the network request was
a call back and the timer was an event
and they don't agree but we can make
them agree which is cool
modeling asynchronous code in tests is
actually possible
so take signals are really easy to mock
and fake out or like create dummy
versions of and we'll see a little bit
like a little bit of that later but
being able to create dummy versions of
timelines is really powerful so it's a
powerful model asynchrony being able to
compose operations in this really
flexible way is really powerful and it's
powerful because it lets me take the
distance between the speck in my head of
how a feature should work or like how a
piece of UI should act and map it to
code in a way that's really readable
it's really cool because I can write
this in a really succinct way so I want
to be able to take like the button
should be enabled when these four fields
have values that are all strings they're
all numbers rather and be able to map
that to a single line in my application
and normally you can't do that you have
to like take a bunch of callbacks and
wear them together
being able to write essentially take the
lines of the spec and then write them as
lines of code or blocks of code is
really powerful without having to spew
it everywhere and then different
callbacks to like fiddle with each
other's stayed accidentally and make a
big mess so this is one of the examples
I really like this feature is called the
undo flash so every time you do anything
and get up for Windows you get this
pop-up and it lets you undo it which is
really important in my opinion a lot of
people were nervous about get
they're like what did I do what I did I
hit a button and now my Nam eyes code is
broken so being always happy to be able
to go back as cool and the interesting
that we got about this rule is that the
way that it is dismissed so it pops up
as soon as you do something and so the
logic is actually a little bit more
complicated and than you think you think
it's just oh yeah it hangs around for a
while then goes away so what it does is
it guarantees what I wanted I wanted to
say hang around for at least five
seconds if any that the user does
anything else that's a hint that they
don't want to undo send it away but we
don't want to like make it go away
immediately because that means as soon
as they like if they move the mouse like
a second like it'll just go pop up pop
down that sucks so we want to hang
around for at least five seconds and
then if they do anything like move the
mouse click you know type something send
it away they they must not have wanted
it or if they wait a really long time
also dismiss it trying to set this up in
the parrot of code wouldn't be succinct
you wouldn't know what they were trying
to do when you read it again and so we
can express in in a single block of code
a really complicated intent like that I
don't know how to do that in any other
framework so we can say like you know
when this original timer fires and
either when either of these two fire
then execute the command we fake hitting
the okay button there's an invisible
button that actually means cancel this
is practical code this is not this is
not theoretical I copy pasted this we
are practical individuals above all else
so Evan talked about time travel
debugging we have something that's not
as cool but still really useful called
time travel testing so remember that
this thing that I described is scheduler
which lets us jump to other threads
anytime an action is deferred it's run
through this object called a scheduler
so you can create a scheduler that
doesn't actually do anything it just
records what you would have done so it
just puts it in a list it's like oh yeah
they what they wanted to in ten seconds
to run this thing and so you just keep
recording whatever they wanted to do and
then at some point you say like
scheduler that's advanced to ten minutes
in and so now you just got a list and
you've got some things in order and so
you run down the list until you get to
10 minutes in as fast as possible
executing it like full speed even though
you're simulating this thing that was
supposed to take a lot of time and so
that way you can write tests that are
deterministic run full speed but
simulate time passing which is really
cool like I had this really good example
that was a Pomodoro timer like these you
know you know time and you wait 20
minutes and then you wait 10 minutes and
then ten minute break and then you go
back to work
and even if you try to set the delays so
you write a bunch of test suite to it
and you set all the times to like really
low like one millisecond two
milliseconds of real time times like a
hundred tests you still end up with a
test suite that is unusable slow and so
this is really cool a lot of stock
traders use this feature of reactive
extensions because what you can do is
you can take canned historical data
stock trading data run all of it through
as if you're running through as if you
sat there you know in real time and
watch this data come in and then you
catch up with a present day and so now
you're watching real time as if you were
doing that the entire time and your code
base is one path you don't have to
create like the historical path where
you run through a file and then you get
the present day and then you come jump
to the completely other code base where
you run through real time just cool
so here's an example of how we test the
relative time so get up always displays
times for commits is like five minutes
ago or like if you're in New Zealand
sometimes it says like two minutes from
now like somehow I don't know time is
weird
in other countries their time zones it's
hard so we do the same thing we override
we say alright we made a commit does it
say just now because we just made this
commit fast-forward five minutes what
does it say now fast-forward five more
minutes does it say like five minutes
ago
does it not so it's cool this is what
every developer who gets really good at
reactive UI and RAC says they're like I
don't know I can't write these like I
don't want to like it doesn't it doesn't
work and that's kind of a sign that I'm
onto a good thing so here's some things
that aren't so good so in a group of
developers when you're writing a
production application most developers
aren't familiar with these concepts even
if they're really good developers and so
one thing we have to do a github is that
every new developer to our application
kind of has to take the RX class and so
you'll find that what kind of like
people will fall back to their old
habits and because they know that it'll
get stuff done and it will but in the
end you'll end up kind of like getting a
little bit of Croft and like it may be a
little bit more crafting like so you'll
be really careful and and like kind of
it takes some time for new developers to
understand this model or really kind of
latch on to it and so if you're in and
if you're in a large group then this can
be definitely something to think about
like a trade-off
UI frameworks care about threads it
really only just cares about one thread
and whether you're on it or not so
Windows will just blow up on you
whenever you try to touch it from the
wrong thread cocoa does even more
insidious things that just like you call
a method nothing happens just it didn't
work I don't know like sorry computers
they're the worst
reactive ey I actually try to solve this
problem and make it really easy and kind
of hide this from developers but it
turns out that making it easy also made
it really slow because these schedules
will read to fir something and say like
put this on the UI thread would end up
stacking and so you end up with this
convoy problem with like I I made a
change which scheduled the UI thread
that was a little bit of latency but now
I did it again and now I did it again
now you have it like 20 times and now
that's a lot of latency in your
application it feels really slow so we
had to tear out all of these features
and make it very manual which is a
bummer but you make vast applications so
it made it possible for large
applications to exist space and time
leaks it turns out that giving
developers the tools to make long chains
of events is cruise control for memory
leaks so because this makes it easy to
tie a bunch of objects together
you've now tied their lifetime together
through event leaks just like in
JavaScript event leaks I spend a lot of
time and get up for Windows in memory
profilers digging around trying to find
event leaks because it's really easy to
leak a small object and you're like oh
that doesn't really matter but then you
look up the chain and eventually it's
like a giant bitmap and you're like oh
because everything is tied to the view
view objects are really heavy and
eventually at some point you'll get to a
view object worried that you leaked and
now you've you caused a lot of problems
it's not a lot of fun to trace down this
and the tooling for it is not ideal so
it's a lot of looking at this kind of
diagram
you're using rocks and sticks basically
but this isn't so it's something to keep
in mind when you started we didn't know
and get app or Windows there was a
specific kind of framework related
memory leak that we didn't know about
and so we're like why are we leaking off
his memory like I don't then we figured
out that it was like a WPF bug and we're
like so the framework will sometimes
conspire against you to leak memory so
one thing that's really isn't a super
big disadvantage but it's something that
you have to really throw out all the
nice things you have is virtualizing
list and so virtualizing list rope and
every mobile platform in cocoa it's
called a UI tableview controller or UI
collection view controller and Android
it's a ListView or like a recycler view
and WPF it's there was you know
virtualizing ListView these lists that
actually hold a certain amount like a
trash stack of views that are recycled
and so as you scroll it doesn't have all
the views in memory because if you have
a look a list of a thousand items you
don't want to have a thousand cells
because you don't have the memory to do
it so you might have like 20 cells and
as you scroll you create new ones or
reuse old ones that creating new ones
you are essentially doing a lot of work
in a draw loop and you have to be really
it's really performance sensitive and we
found that the methods to create
observables or signals or and set them
up was too expensive to do inside for
for really complicated user interfaces
so people would scroll and they'd see
like this like grind as it is it this is
an uncommon problem like scrolling in
iOS and Android is very difficult to get
really good you just basically have to
do less stuff so it's just hard and so
you can definitely run into that problem
GC pauses on Android are a super bummer
Rx laws are really small objects
the call stacks in in these in Rx and
RAC can get pretty ridiculous so this is
an example there's an iOS application so
the top of the button the bug is
actually really simple like it's just
like right there like line three
it's actually like a like a runtime like
a GC bug where we just didn't marshal
the object right jumped into nowhere so
that's part of the call stack let me
keep going so we haven't got there yet
we're still looking through and the
problem is that at least with c-sharp a
lot of the names have been stripped
because they use anonymous classes and
so you don't know the operators you're
actually going through and still like it
if you take that calls that can grep out
the word system not reactive and that
actually is a pretty readable call stack
but you end up with these like crazy
long it's like let's keep going let's
keep going
and there we go we're at main three
pages later so that can be intimidating
to new developers this is using yeah
samurai OS so this is they took a
c-sharp application they pre compile
everything ahead of time because Apple
doesn't allow JIT and they this is
actually a native call stack but they do
a trick where they make all the native
function names to be like c-sharp
function names so when you get the
native stack like you crack it out of
the console dot log you see something
that you can kind of interpret as a it
was pretty clever so a lot of these
problems if we had good tools and like
we could like hack into kind of the
internals of it and since a lot of this
is open source we can we can make a lot
of these things way better and so we're
at get up trying to think just like
barely starting to think about like how
can we make this how can we make this
better for developers because when we
make it better we make it more
approachable I want everyone to be able
to great UI applications in the
style but right now like they fall into
the pit of of this somewhere and so
that's not great
so tooling can help us out one thing
that's really important if you do decide
to write this in your application
logging and tracing is really useful
logging signals in particular will help
you debug a lot of what's going on
signals are really cool because they're
natively what's called a dual point log
so what's a span it's a certain amount
of time and if you can visualize that
you get a lot of cool things and so yeah
logging signals in an area obviously
that's important so this is a tool that
I use in WPF it's basically the best
part of Visual Studio this is called the
concurrency visualizer and what it does
is it lets you they log everything using
like the essentially the windows version
of dtrace called etw which is impossible
to use unless you're inside Microsoft
but they made this tool that I can at
least see kinda what's going on so this
is there's a view of a bunch of threads
and each color code is a kind of thing
you're doing and you can see a little
bit of in the corner and I'll have a
great screen shot and so the important
thing is to look at the main thread and
you basically want the entire thing to
be brown because the brown means
processing UI messages it is brown that
means it's responding to user input if
it's any other color this is actually a
really bad trace like this application
sucks because you can see like at four
seconds in that they start grabbing
locks everywhere
red is synchronization and if you click
on any of those you can see how long it
was you can see the thread that
unblocked you and it'll like kind of
point like I'll be like this ran from
here and it was waiting on this and like
it's a really cool tool and if I could
jam my own data into it if I could have
signals in that view it'd be really
useful and it make debugging
applications really easy especially even
ones that are really asynchronous and
have all kinds of things going on in
different threads
so there's a really cool tool that I
want to like rebuild but integrated into
our X I have a lot of plans but not
enough time I need more hands basically
it's height faster reactive cocoa has
DTrace integration you can view this
trace and instruments instruments is not
extensible in many any super interesting
way so this is this is the best you can
get out of it it's kind of a bummer
be really cool because they have all
these visualizations and if you could
Jam arbitrary data into it that'd be
awesome
so let's steal the ideas of instruments
but make it so that applications can
write their own their own stuff it works
for both iOS and App kit trap grabbing
grabbing these traces so nobody's ever
seen this before one of the developers
on the desktop team named Marcus Olson
is working on a tool to visualize
signals so this is super cool that I'm
really excited about this this is gonna
be amazing
I want to bring it every on every
platform he did this by like abusing the
dotnet runtime to be able to hack
methods and like replace like hook them
basically and so we can see like this
timer and the timer dot select timer it
out where and you can't see the lines
but there's lines connecting these
there's a it's a graph like in a
basically graphic and at the bottom we
can see that somebody's Sony's watching
it and we can see how many instances are
live of each of each thing and if it's
red that means it ended in an error
right like throw immediately ads so I'm
almost out of time but this is a little
last slide and so tools like this will
make it so that this is really useable
and cool or like we had like it kind of
some ideas around overviews like be able
to see all the errors that were thrown
and then kind of debug and like and what
point in that graph did it happen stuff
like that so having these kind of tools
will turn it will turn
the ideas of functional reactive
programming kind of bring them to
everyone in a way that is approachable
so I think tooling is a big part of that
and so cool so that's all I got
thank you so much for your time
questions comments concerns rants
Tomatoes throne
how much time do you think it takes for
someone to make
sure so the question was how how long
does it take to kind of move from an
imperative mindset to a functional
mindset I think it's a progress you can
definitely one of the cool things is you
can kind of like apply this piecemeal to
your application you don't have to
completely buy into it or completely not
and so you can kind of try it out on
maybe like a single view and then see
how that works and and it's there's
definitely a learning curve it's
unfortunate it's you know take some time
to really like map your brain a
different way than you're used to but
yeah I think that typically get up you
know get up hires really good developers
we're really fortunate to be able to
hire really smart people it takes them
about a good like six months to really
like turn their brain around
no would be really cool we don't record
it ever like it's always just like get
some developers in a room we're gonna
wait board some stuff let's go
like what the thing with that I think
one more question we're out of time
I totally agree but like yeah like if we
can buy some pitchforks will storm
Cupertino like I live right nearby like
we just roll in and be like guys I'm
sick of pointers aren't great I don't
want to but yeah so I mean racking and
reactive you I definitely compromise
it's living within a system that is
definitely not designed for it and so
yeah so having having a a really
beautiful functional UI toolkit would be
really cool
a little bird has told me that like
apples thinking about this they notice
react with cocoa and they notice that
it's kind of this different thing that
it's really useful and I think that
they're at least a lot of their
engineers are kind of taking these ideas
to heart but maybe in a perhaps more
like you know when you're out of you I
took it for every person in the world
then you have to think of it and it
really like you give them the pieces and
people can build what they want right it
has to be really like approachable and
so I think that's definitely compromise
that they have to make okay yep all
right thank you so much
[Applause]